[Music]
foreign
folks welcome to the Dark Horse podcast
live stream number 150 some large digit
yeah 56 56. I was thinking it was higher
than that but 156 it's definitely unless
I failed to increase it it is it's 156
it's 156 wow it is 2023 and we are after
a roaring start what number is it again
156 yes yes yeah
um right well here we are
here we are uh today we are going to
talk a bit about
can we even say the word at this point
or is it still Voldemort uh no I believe
we can say the word we can say the word
I think if we pronounce it in British
then we're safe so today we might be
talking about Ivermectin that wasn't
British no I don't know what that was
what I don't know I was going to say
even which I don't think is pronounced
oh just it's plausible as long as there
are no Brits watching I think it'll do
okay I thought you meant an accent as
opposed to a different pronunciation
but I can't like it doesn't have enough
I don't even know can we start over
laughs either mechton
this is going to be the thing that
finally cancels us yes yes finally yeah
to Yanks many people's great relief and
others tremendous horror that was the
wrong two
I thought you were gonna say two Yanks
finally push two Yanks finally pushed it
too a bit too far indeed okay so we're
gonna talk about Ivermectin a little bit
and then um some organizations that seem
to have lost the plot the Red Cross the
American Museum of Natural History
a biological organization uh for which
you ended up at the conference of this
yes I did somehow I went through biology
conference yeah you didn't actually go
to the biology conference you went to
Austin to talk to to Joe Rogan awesome
Joe Rogan the awesome Joe Rogan but I
did go to a biology and the hotel you're
at happened to be hosting a biology
conference crash the biology conference
yes you did yes yes you did Sir can talk
about that a little bit and we're also
going to talk about fourth grade me
trying not to lose the plot at the end
all right no idea where that's going but
no okay but first some Logistics uh find
and follow Dark Horse now on Twitter
LinkedIn Facebook Instagram uh we now
have accounts there and we've got some
some awesome people
monitoring those accounts and putting up
content and there will be announcements
of things like schedule changes and um
and blast from the past and blasphemy
from the past even
probably yeah yeah
we follow these live streams with live q
and A's cues and is Q's a yeah you can
ask questions at darker submissions.com
we uh also are streaming on Odyssey is
that correct Mr Producer ma'am okay we
are produced we are producing we are
streaming on Odyssey and that is where
the chat is live if you are watching us
live you can go over there
and
um we encourage you to check out our
book hunter gatherers guide the 21st
century my substag natural
selections.substech.com where uh this
week I wrote about connecting and my
desire to befriend seals among other
things
proving seals
I guess I need them to be approving if I
am to befriend them yes of course I will
let everyone fill in their own punchline
on that yes indeed we have a terrific
store uh darkhorsestore.org with lots of
awesome products including the lot lie
to a tyrant hoodie which we got a couple
in the mail and I presented it to our
younger awesome 16 year old son and he
worked to school he did yeah as long as
he doesn't take us to be tyrants I think
it's good no he uh he he looked at it
he's like Stalin yeah
yeah lie to Stalin got it absolutely
okay uh and we are of course supported
by you our audience we appreciate you
subscribing to the channels uh both
YouTube and odyssey and the clips
Channel Dark Horse podcast Clips on both
of those and wherever it is that you are
watching or listening to the podcast
being on Spotify or apple podcast or
wherever and sharing uh like it you know
subscribing liking and sharing when you
when you feel like uh you should be
doing so uh YouTube of course
demonetized us a long time ago at this
point and uh as such we appreciate any
financial support you can uh you can
throw at us we have uh patreons where
there are active communities and you
also can get access to a private monthly
q a on mine and Brett has conversations
on his one of which was this morning the
second of which this month will be
tomorrow morning tomorrow morning 9 A.M
Pacific uh and they are fantastic you
can also there get access to our Discord
server well where conversations are
ongoing and include things like karaoke
and and book clubs and of course we have
sponsors for whom we are very very
grateful and we do not accept
sponsorship from uh from corporations
that make products or offer services
that we actually don't vouch for so you
can be sure that if we are reading ads
as we do at the top of each live stream
three ads then we have actually vetted
and and approved these products so
without further Ado our current sponsors
their first sponsors for 2023 include
the house of macadamias this is they're
brand new to us nuts that's right house
of macadamias makes makes they grow and
they package and they put into some
remarkable forms macadamia nuts
tree nuts which includes not just
macadamias but also pecans walnuts
cashews almonds pistachios and more are
delicious and nutritious they are
generally high in fat and low in
carbohydrates which is increasingly
understood to be both satiating and good
for you despite what the food pyramid
may have told you also yum
uh that's the delicious part oh right oh
it was included there yes highfalutin
language delicious and yeah that's super
high polluted delicious
it's moderately flute it's it's
moderately fluten as our macadamias
out there I don't know the high and
awesome hi an awesome pollutant yes but
each species of nut is different and for
many of us and for good reason
macadamias are the best macadamia nuts
take a very long time to grow however
and are rare representing only about a
one percent of nuts in the marketplace
and because they are both rare and
highly sought after they have the
dubious distinction of being the world's
most expensive nut but between the taste
and the health benefits they're worth it
they have fewer carbohydrates than most
of their nuts for instance half of what
cashews or pistachios have and
two-thirds of what almonds have which
makes them the perfect snack for
breaking a daily fast and controlling
blood glucose they're also uniquely rich
in omega-7s including especially
Palmetto layic I think I'm pronouncing
that correctly palmatolic acid an
unsaturated fat that has been linked to
Natural collagen production fat loss and
heart health and I will say here just
another side I actually went and looked
at um I did a little literature review
on macadamia nuts and and what what
people are finding out about them and it
is a burgeoning field of research
because macadamia nuts really do seem to
be quite remarkable in many ways quite
good for you and House of macadamias
which is our newest sponsor is a company
obsessed with making this amazing food
accessible to everyone they have
partnered with more than 90 farmers in
Africa and now make one of a kind vegan
keto and paleo stacks these include
their white chocolate dipped macadamias
and dark chocolate dipped macadamias
plus a delicious assembly of bars made
with 45 macadamia nuts including mocha
salted caramel and chocolate coconut and
they're all great and they have Simply
Delicious salted macadamias made with
namibian sea salt they're amazing we
love them and we think that you will too
so our house of academias recommends
House of macadamias for all of your
macadamic needs looking for something to
nourish and energize you while in
pursuit of the truth or the next Summit
go to
www.houseamacademias.com that's
houseofmaca
d-a-m-i-a-s.com and use code Darkhorse
for a 20 discount on your first order
all right and with that we go to our
second sponsor and our second sponsor is
eight sleep and I must tell you while I
was on the road I missed the ability to
control the temperature of the bed just
so you weren't able to turn your bed
into an ice cube no I had to use the the
room temperature which is just not a
good substitute it's just not as
effective no its lip is fabulous yes
they are all right so good sleep is a
game changer and the eight sleep pod
helps you get good sleep as we discussed
in the Sleep chapter of the
hunter-gatherers guide intelligent life
that found its way to Earth might be
surprised by a lot of what it found on
our planet but likely not by the fact of
sleep or dreams sleep is necessary
without good sleep we are destined to be
unhealthy and unproductive
consistent good sleep can help you
reduce the likelihood of serious health
issues decrease the risk of heart
disease lower blood blood pressure and
even reduce the risk of Alzheimer's
but more than 30 percent of Americans
struggle with sleep and temperature is
one of the main reasons couples who
sleep together often have different
optimal sleep temperatures Heather which
can cause all sorts of disagreements
also Heather eight sleep allows
fine-tuned temperature regulation for
both people having a cool room and a
warm bed is a luxury that eight sleep
makes easy to obtain not that you want
that no
um the Pod Pro cover by eight sleep is
the only sleep technology with dinette
that dynamically cools and heats each
side of the bed to maintain the optimal
sleeping temperature for what your body
needs with the Pod you can start
sleeping as cool as 55 degrees
Fahrenheit so nice or as hot as 110
yikes not that we recommend the extremes
so some of us recommend close to one of
those close to one of those extremes but
it's good oh my God it goes down to
negative 10 units and that's not
temperature units and you started off at
negative eight
my God it's so cold delightful but all
right
um but you can do this and not
antagonize your partner and that's
amazing and not antagonize your partner
right exactly
um the temperature of the cover will
adjust each side of the bed based on
your uh your sleep stages Biometrics
bedroom temperature reacting dynamically
to create the optimal sleeping
environment eight sleep users fall
asleep 32 faster reduce sleep
interruptions by 40 and get 30 percent
more deep sleep on average with more
restful sleep overall you may see
improvements in physical recovery
hormone regulation and mental Clarity
finally the alarm feature which I used
only this morning
uh which can wake you with temperature
change and or slight chest level
vibrations is so much gentler than any
standard alarm
we were both a little skeptical and now
we are totally sold we are surprised by
how much we appreciate this bed go to
eightsleep.com Darkhorse to check out
the Pod Pro cover and save 150 bucks at
checkout eight sleep currently ships
within the USA Canada and the UK and
select countries in the EU and Australia
and I have to say I do not know why but
my phone it doesn't matter what I set
the alarm to it wakes up with that same
blaring thing I can't adjust you're not
talking about the eat sleep app you're
talking about your phone yeah so anyway
I was watching reading it I had to get
up early this morning and
um I realized how I've got the perfect
solution right here so I did not use the
phone at all no and it just the bed your
side of the bed just vibrated lightly
and you wake up yep earthquake nope nope
and yeah I mean just like with the
temperature you can set it to vibrate
not at all up through 10 level I haven't
tried that I don't know yeah it's really
like necessary I mean yeah
all right our final sponsor this week is
seed seed is a company focused on
bacteria and the microbiome and they
have a terrific probiotic called ds01
daily symbiotic I always prefer eating
real food to taking pills but I have to
say I really love this product
there are a lot of things that you can
do to enhance your health our sign off
here at Dark Horse includes three of
them be good to the ones you love eat
good food and get outside but a lot is
hidden in those words what for instance
constitutes constitutes good food good
food is real food whole food food that
has been alive recently and was grown
with care and conditions as ancient as
possible given the constraints of the
21st Century
but even many people who eat such a diet
are missing something
we contain multitudes every individual
human can hint so many other organisms
some of which may harm us but many of
which exist with us in harmony we need
them this is why probiotics can be an
important tool in a healthy lifestyle
even if you eat nutrient-dense food and
avoid processed foods and sugar but not
all probiotics are created equally
seeds DSO one daily symbiotic is a broad
spectrum two in one probiotic and
Prebiotic it contains 24 distinct
probiotic strains and a two in one
capsule that protects the probiotics
until they hit the colon where they are
most effective if you've taken a
probiotic before and never felt a
difference it's likely because the good
bacteria weren't surviving your GI tract
see this design differently and that's
why it works
seeds daily symbiotic supports gut skin
and heart health and micronutrient
synthesis we've heard from several
people who've used seed and Report
improvements to the digestive function
in 24 to 48 hours start a new healthy
habit today visit seed.com Darkhorse and
use code Darkhorse to redeem 20 off your
first month of seeds dso1 daily
symbiotic that's seed.com s-e-d dot
slash Darkhorse and use code Darkhorse
at checkout
all right
that
is it that's the business the
sponsorships that's for the for the
business and um
we were going to start off today talking
about
the mechanism of action of ivermectin
what mechanism of action of iron record
I remember I remember a particularly
nasty interaction where one of our
detractors took me to task for admitting
that I did not know by what mechanism
Ivermectin seemed to be working and she
said and if you don't know it must not
work right exactly how can you say that
something works without if you don't
know the mechanism of action and of
course that's not how science works at
all you can absolutely know that
something works and not know the
mechanism of action but it's frankly
such a mechanistic approach to science
is almost always hand in hand with a
reductionist approach and almost always
revealing of a relatively small mind who
may generate sort of bricks in the wall
that already exist in science but is
very unlikely to discover new truths it
is 100 not the way that science has to
work there is good mechanistic science
out there as I think this paper we're
going to talk about today reveals but
the idea that if you don't know
mechanism you can't know the thing is
functional no right and any fool knows
this right I mean how how many people
how many games of Ultimate Frisbee have
taken place entirely on a field with
nobody on it who could explain what the
relationship is between the Bernoulli
effect and the way the damn thing flies
right no you just know how to throw the
frisbee right so anyway yeah knowing how
it works it's not essential but it's
fantastic when it happens because it
allows you to go that much farther you
can extrapolate in ways that you could
not necessarily otherwise extrapolate so
anyway it's great that a mechanism of
action seems to have emerged indeed so
um we ran across this on Dr McCullough's
substack
he published a short piece called
ivermectin's mechanism of action against
Stars Kobe 2 described shame on the
hospital symptoms
shame on the hospital systems that
systematically denied patients and their
begging families this FDA approved Nobel
prize-winning wonder drug
he is talking about he is referring to
this paper that came out in the
international Journal of molecular
Sciences which you can show on my screen
if you like Zach
um just
recently it's actually end of 2022 and
the title is SARS Kobe 2 Spike protein
induces hemagglutination
implications for covid-19 morbidities
and Therapeutics and for vaccine adverse
effects
okay
I think we had talked about me just
sharing a couple of excerpts from the
paper before we talk about it yes well
it was one other thing that was I don't
remember if it's in the paper it was
certainly in McCullough's brief
treatment of it which I wanted to remind
people of because there has been so much
effort put into confusing people about
Ivermectin and whether or not it works
for SARS cov2 that I just wanted to um
to highlight this uh this piece of
information which is that Ivermectin was
known to have broad scale effects
against
RNA viruses generally there's a large
number of RNA viruses in which it has
been shown to be useful so to the extent
that people are scratching their heads
over why a dewormer has an effect on uh
SARS Kobe 2. that's not what it is this
is a highly bioactive molecule that has
effects yes on parasitic worms also
appears to have effects counteracting
RNA viruses of which SARS cov2 is of
course one yep so not a lot of them and
we and we wrote that into the piece that
we published on my sub stack as well and
you know it it is
it is a kind of a wonder drug and
there's a reason that it was on the
whose list of essential medicines and
that's not Roger daltrey's doing that's
the other who and that's the who that is
since like you know taken out Roger
dalty comes from well you know until
2020 when you said the who most people
who weren't associated with the World
Health Organization are in that sphere
somehow I would think you know Peter P
Townsend and red adultery and such but
you know this isn't this isn't a sleight
of hand on our part going like yeah some
you know rock stars think that
Ivermectin works like no the who it's
still on their list of essential
medicines and
um I believe it's back on a number of
other health agencies list of
recommended medicines for copen2 but I
did not look into that it is actually I
checked before the podcast I have to
delve deeper to see exactly what it
means but it is actually on the NIH site
um so it wasn't actually so be careful
there because it wasn't an age site for
a while and but they basically said yeah
but not really yeah so I don't know if
it's something research or something
like that but anyway it's it's uh it's
beside the point I will point out that
in terms of yes you can know that
something works before you know how it
is that it works that there is also
something to be said for the integrative
aspect of this right you have a
bacterium found in Japanese soil I
believe a golf course was the original
Source no I didn't know that um but in
any case that makes it weirder in a way
it does make it weird selective effects
from the stuff you have to put on grass
to make it into a golf course either
that or it's very tolerant and uh
Satoshi omura was at the golf course
because it's a place that brings people
I don't know exactly what the
explanation would be but the thing that
I would point out is there's bound to be
a fascinating ecological
story
underlying the question of why this
bacterium has effects against a broad
range of creatures in other words if you
studied the bacterium instead of
studying the compound you might find
that it has a unique environment in
which fending off these things is
particularly relevant to some story I
think that we don't yet know and I would
love to hear that story how is it that
some
creature as inconspicuous as this one
came to have all of these effects that
we find so useful right and without
understanding why or even what yet what
many of the effects were uh the
discovery by umara uh won him a Nobel
Prize back in 2015 2015. so not that
long ago actually even though the
discovery was many decades before that
is as often the case with the I mean
maybe always the case with the Nobel
right at least in physiology and
Medicine
um that the award gets granted
um often decades after the discovery in
question I think all of the Sciences
maybe peace not so much and maybe
literature not so much although
literature tends to be across for a
lifetime anyway I digress yeah
yeah neither here nor there
um okay so this article uh published in
the international Journal of molecular
Sciences finds that and you may show my
screen if you like Zach this is just the
second half of the abstract the results
of these experiments were first that
Spike protein from these four lineages
of SARS cov2 induced ha which is
um hemagglutination
assay I want to say that has to be sail
of the way they've got this um
that's weird
um
Omicron induced h a at a significantly
lower threshold concentration of Spike
protein than the three prior lineages
and was much more electropositive on its
Central spec protein region IBM it's
Ivermectin blocked h a when added to red
blood cells prior to spike protein and
reversed
hemoglutination when added afterwards
these results validate and extend prior
findings on the role of glycan bindings
of viral Spike protein and covid-19 they
furthermore suggest therapeutic options
using competitive glycan binding agents
such as Ivermectin and may help
elucidate rare serious adverse effects
associated with covid-19 mRNA vaccines
which use Spike protein as a generated
antigen so that's highly technical as
abstracts will tend to be but it clears
up a little bit with a few more a few
more sections
um and for those glycan is just a
polysaccharide
so
hemagglutinating property basically just
means clumping okay
um so this clumping of red blood cells
this hemagglutinating property of SARS
cov2 has important clinical consequences
first with trillions of red blood cells
each circulating through narrow
pulmonary capillaries about once per
minute even small dynamically
aggregating and disaggregating red blood
cell clumps as can form even in the
absence of pathogens can impede red
blood cell oxygenation
peripheral ischemia endothelial damage
and Vascular occlusion are indeed
frequently observed in serious cases of
covid-19 as reviewed in these references
in covid-19 patients damaged endothelium
of pulmonary capillaries is often
observed adjoining relatively intact
alveoli while hypoxemia is manifested
despite normal breathing mechanism
mechanics these morbidities of covid-19
parallel those of severe malaria in
which clumping of parasite infected red
blood cells to other red blood cells via
sa I don't remember what that is
terminal residues and endothelial
cyto-adhesion also often result in fatal
outcomes so they are saying this looks
similar to malaria we now are seeing
what SARS cov2 is doing which is it's
causing red blood cells to Clump the
word being hemagglutination and and we
the authors of this paper are putting
together that that thing that we are
seeing with the observation the clinical
observations of how it is that people
suffering from Bad cases of covid are
manifesting in terms of their symptoms
so
um I don't know if you want to continue
there or I want to add a couple of
things so to translate some of that it
is counterintuitive that capillary beds
are actually basically composed of uh
of
arterials that are so tiny that
basically the blood cells go through
close to single file and any clumping
causes these things not to be able to
get through and what they're saying is
that that results in damage from these
tissues not being perfused with oxygen
and any tissue that is denied oxygen
long enough basically ends up dying
which they're saying matches some of the
pathologies that we see from a severe
covet infection may also say
up the lungs are failing to engage in
gas exchange even though the mechanics
are working and the basic point is in
order for gas exchange to work the blood
has to get right to this very cusp of
contact with the air that you're
breathing in and to the extent that the
capillary beds in your alveoli are not
perfused with blood cells because the
blood cells can't get in single file to
get into those tiny little arterioles
it's not working so they're not
presumably dumping carbon dioxide and
picking up oxygen which then results in
the the hypoxia that was talked about so
much earlier in the covet pandemic yeah
uh just just a semantic Point
um so the heart
as mammals we have a fully four
chambered heart in which uh you know we
have blood coming out of the heart and
going to systemically coming back in and
then going to the other side of the
heart and going out into the Lum lungs
the lungs the lungs and then back and in
both of those circuits be it out to the
body uh and then back or out to the
lungs and then back you basically go go
out on the biggest biggest most
muscularized vessels the arteries and
then as they get smaller there's no real
category difference but like then they
become arterials and then at the point
that they are at their most at their
smallest where the blood cells May in
fact be going single file we call those
capillary beds we don't really call them
arterioles at least over in comparative
biology land where I'm you know never
dissected a human but detected a lot of
cats
um and then you know as they come out of
the capillary beds like venules I think
veins as they get bigger you know and
veins are um are under much less
pressure and so the sides of them are
are much less thick and they tend to you
know you end up with these um pools
pools in your veins potentially if you
weren't otherwise very healthy or if
you're old in a way that you don't
really get pools in your in your
arteries because the blood coming
directly out of your heart before it
hits capillaries is under fairly high
pressure but after having gone through
the capillary beds it's coming back more
sluggishly and also deoxygenated and the
thing about the alveoli of the lungs is
that basically the lung the lungs the
the pulmonary circuit out of the heart
is is a way to get the blood back into
oxygenated state right so you know the
pulmonary artery is the least oxygenated
vessel in the body
at least oxygenated big vessel in the
body even though in general when we
think of arteries it's like oh you know
the blood is pumping fast it's full of
oxygen but only if it's recently come
back from the lung system that's now
going out into the body right and so
um so I did screw up I used arterial or
I should have said capillary but in any
case
um it's amazing how well this actually
fits a lot of the stuff that was
discussed early in covet the hypoxia is
basically if you imagine that what you
did you know even if your red blood
cells are just uh a little bit tending
to stick together that's enough to keep
them from flowing through those
capillary beds the way they're supposed
to and so you can imagine they put that
pulse ox thing on your finger and
basically what it's reading is that to
the extent that oxygenated blood landed
in your tissues like the ones in your
fingers it burned its oxygen and then
wasn't in a position to go back and play
another round of the game
um and so you would see this now what I
don't hear explained in here is why
the you will remember that the syndrome
was called something like happy hypoxics
if you had people who had such low
oxygenation that they should have been
on the floor and yet they didn't even
register to themselves that they were
struggling to to oxygenate so I'm
looking for I'm waiting for that
explanation yeah but uh anyway so far
interesting yeah so a few more uh a few
more bits from this paper
uh this is just something that we've
talked about before but Ivermectin
achieved Nobel Prize honored distinction
for Success against Global parasitic
scourges but is of disputed efficacy in
the treatment of covid-19 as indicated
for example by the disparity in the
conclusions of this editorial cited and
its key cited meta-analysis cited so
this is just so these authors like all
the authors trying to publish all the
scientists trying to publish on covid
right now who are in any way dissidents
from the mainstream narrative uh have to
have to do a little bit of this like oh
but the vaccines are great oh but you
know things don't work when we've been
told they don't work even if they really
kind of do and so there's always a
little you know there's there's ways
that you can get in the critique and
this is them doing that the conclusions
of the editorial that they cite
um are are you know we need to stop
using drugs that don't work and then the
meta-analysis and that includes
Ivermectin and the meta-analysis that
that editorial sites finds that it does
work so
um you know even even the
even the medical journals that are
supposed to be that that seem to be
doing the right thing are um are are
just are citing things backwards
throughout throughout well I guess what
you're saying is you can detect the uh
the massive force that wants to tell you
what you can and cannot say even in a
paper that's reporting something here
that's clearly a Vindication of those
who have been demonized but this is but
no but no this is them going like yeah
look look at what these guys Clarity
between the yeah yeah and but you have
to you have to I'm not going to do it
here but you're like you have I did
before became on camera you have to go
and looks like oh okay so this is them
revealing something that the Casual
reader won't be revealed but it's but
it's in here okay so um
sorry about the scrolling where's the
next thing
uh h a hemoglo
hemagglutinating okay so that's just the
the tendency of the red blood cells to
stick together
the hemoglobinating inducing activity of
SARS cov2 Spike protein which is
especially potent for Omicron raises
questions as a potential risks for Cobin
19 mRNA vaccines which use Spike protein
as the generated antigen even though
serious adverse effects linked to spike
proteins such as myocarditis are rare
detectable levels of SARS Kobe 2 Spike
protein and S1 and serum or plasma have
been found to persist for as long as 50
days following such vaccinations
the possibility that Spike protein
migrating into the bloodstream could in
rare cases prompt such hemoglutinating
Associated Adverse Events is suggested
for example by a study of a thousand six
subjects experiencing Adverse Events
after receiving a Pfizer bioen Tech or
moderna mRNA vaccination which found a
significant degree of red blood cell
aggregation in the blood of 948 of those
subjects 148 of a thousand six these
risks may be increased for younger age
groups with 301 adolescents of 13 to 18
years of age who receive two doses of
the bioentec MRNA covid-19 vaccine in
one study having a 29.2 percent rate of
cardiac Adverse Events ranging from
tachycardia or palpitation to myoperic
myopericarditis wow
wow yeah so what they're saying I should
say there's a
piece of conservatism in here that
doesn't that needs to be highlighted
which is that yes the spike protein has
been found up to 50 days but it's
actually been found longer than that and
we really don't know at what rate it
dissipates I remember I uh I know you're
going somewhere persist for as long as
50 days following such vaccinations
I did not click through on these links
but I remember us talking in an earlier
Dark Horse about some of the research
that was finding that it was persisting
and the research was saying you know up
to up to 50 days or something like that
and when you go into the paper it
actually says well we actually just
stopped looking after 50 days so it's
not that they are saying and then it's
gone they're saying and then we don't
know which is an important distinction I
don't know that I don't know if that's
the case here but it may well be
um it is also the case that people
should remember the spike protein is not
supposed to be free-floating after these
vaccines anyway right it's supposed to
be sticking in the membrane of the cells
that have been transfected and those
cells are not supposed to be anywhere
and everywhere in the body they're
supposed to be limited to the deltoid
and the lymphatic system associated with
it uh where the antigen presenting cells
were supposed to pass it off to the uh
the immunological cells the bees and T
cells that learn the formula and anyway
so the point is we're talking about
design failure after design failure the
choice of Spike protein
itself dangerous why well you know no at
least one reason why which is that it
caused causes the chemo agglutinating
inducing it's right
and
so choice of the spike protein in fact
the spike protein is showing up
independent of the cells that that were
transfected uh all of these things are
suggesting a kind of uh blood disorder
that is
mimicking malaria
um and
now there's a whole other story that we
could get into but um but nonetheless
the idea that this is creating this
overall malfunction of the red blood
cell half of the system uh is is
profoundly disturbing yeah and
um the mechanism of action therefore uh
I don't know if you had a piece you
wanted to read or if we should just
describe it in plain English
yeah we'll do this first and then we'll
translate into plain English good
Ivermectin a macro a macro cyclic
lactone indicated to bind strongly to
multiple glycan sites on SARS Kobe 2
Spike protein blocked hemagglutination
when added to red blood cells prior to
spike protein and reversed
hemagglutination when added afterwards
which suggests therapeutic options for
covid-19 treatment using this drug or
other competitive glycan binding agents
so
um that's that's not you know that's in
a dish right
uh but uh Ivermectin blocks
hemagglutination
before exposure and it reverses
hemoglobination after exposure to the
spike protein in a dish a petri dish uh
suggesting that given that we now know
that one of if not the primary mechanism
of action by which SARS Kobe 2 is doing
damage to people is hemagglutination
and we know separately that IBM that
Ivermectin and it's not the only one
that does it but that Ivermectin is both
incredibly safe and oops effective in
blocking or prevent blocking or
reversing hemagglutination hey it works
against coven yeah it works against
covid also potentially works against uh
vaccine Adverse Events that are caused
by Spike protein
um I will say it is if this paper holds
it is a validation of one of the
hypotheses that we explored early on
that the mechanism of action of
ivermectin might be The Binding of Spike
protein that that might be why it has
General applicability
um and there's one other thing yeah I'm
not I don't think it's
but that's not that's not what's going
on here it's not binding the spike
protein what uh the question is is so
you will also recall that with Dr Malone
on the episode that I did with him and
Steve Kirsch we talked about the fact
that the spike protein is covered in
these sugars yeah right it's covered in
these sugars presumably as effectively a
cloaking mechanism right so if it is
pulling these sugars out of the blood
and therefore being encrusted in
something that doesn't trigger the
immune system that allows it to evade
the surveillance that happens there and
so anyway it's interesting how this
result seems to line up with some of the
speculating that we did about why things
functioned the way they did early on in
the pandemic before this stuff was known
so it's kind of kind of cool it's it's
very cool
and uh
you know it's not misinformation it's
not disinformation but it's probably
still malinformation because it's true
and it makes you distrust your
government yeah yeah
um I'm not sure what we can do about
that really I mean a better government I
think better wow yeah yeah you said a
mouthful right yeah so if we had
trustworthy government then we could at
least be emotionally disturbed at things
that made you distrusted but with a
distrustful government it's hard to know
if you're just distrusting it because it
sucks right yeah you can't know if
you're paranoid if they're actually
after you exactly it's very hard to
diagnose paranoia when out to get you
um yeah yeah
um yes all right all right so there
um yeah I mean let's just say this this
is this is exciting for more than one
reason a it's beginning to fill in a
piece of the puzzle B it's
operationalizable yeah right to the
extent that people just go a mechanism
is cool we don't need it
often but it's cool when you got it but
it's cool it's cool when you got it and
I actually I remember I don't think
Pierre said this on the podcast but he
certainly said it to me and maybe us
privately
that as he was discovering that
Ivermectin was not only a great
preventative for covid a great treatment
for covid but it also worked uh for long
covet and and uh Adverse Events he was
like this kind of sucks because I feel
like a one-trick pony keep pointing
people to this stuff but it works right
and anyway this begins to explain why it
is that it just sort of generally useful
in this because Spike protein is such a
large part of the pathology associated
with both the disease and the the
so-called vaccines well and I think I I
read it but I glossed over it because it
was a highly technical paragraph but um
you know they also say the
hemagglutinating property of Cyrus Kobe
2 is much reduced in Omicron and so
quite separately and I don't know I
don't know if he said it publicly but to
us Dr Cory when we got Omicron a year
ago
um he said yeah you could take the
Ivermectin but it seems to be not as
effective with with Omicron and that is
also consistent with this finding that
Omar Khan has a lower hemo
hemagglutinating
tendency than the other uh strains isn't
it crazy when all of the lines of
evidence line up yeah yeah
okay should we talk about the since
we're talking about blood let's talk
about the red
oh hell yeah
and and Fairfax who loves to talk about
the rest sir semi-domesticated animal
indeed
uh
okay where do I even start here
the Red Cross
sorry I gotta um
figure out what I'm doing here
okay
um
I will link to the page but I'm just
going to show you a series of
screenshots
um
yeah with with regard to things that are
coming up on the Red Cross site at the
moment
um they have lgbtq plus donors
this page is supported by the American
Red Cross lgbtq plus team member
Resource Group learn about Federal
Regulations related to blood donation by
lesbian gay bisexual transgender queer
intersex asexual and gender
non-conforming individuals
American Red Cross values
if anyone watching doesn't know what the
American Red Cross is which I find
dubious there are a lot of things but in
the United States anyway the primary way
that Americans end up running into them
is with blood drives they are I think by
far the largest collector of blood
often encouraging people to donate blood
uh and actually just yeah now you can
leave my screen up uh and uh and
therefore distributor of blood
and of course back in the 80s uh when uh
uh I I think most of these most of these
sort of Corrections to who could donate
when were happening in the 80s with the
AIDS pandemic
pandemic epidemic epidemic maybe I don't
know when AIDS came on the scene and had
everyone terrified and then you know in
short order people were beginning to get
sort of a handle on well who's really at
risk
uh there were of course restrictions put
in place in terms of who could donate
blood and one of those restrictions was
men who have sex with men which we'll
see this here in a minute MSM is the
acronym non-acronym the abbreviation
they're using men who have sex with men
uh and have had sex with men within the
last three months are not allowed to
donate are on a a temporary hold and if
you are a man who has sex with man but
hasn't had sex with any men in the
previous three months then you're
allowed to donate because because uh
many sexually uh transmitted diseases
stay in the blood and are particularly
suited to transmission uh through uh
male homosexual sex and so American Red
Cross values such as the background
our top priority they say is the safety
of our volunteer blood donors and the
patients in need of life-saving blood
products our employees and volunteers
are trained to be sensitive to the needs
of all potential blood donors
the American Red Cross believes blood
donation eligibility should not be
determined by methods that are based
upon sexual orientation
we are committed to working with
Partners towards achieving this goal
we understand that there is a difference
between biological sex and gender
no they don't the Food and Drug
Administration guidance revised
recommendations for reducing the risk of
human immunodeficiency virus
transmission by Blood and blood products
States quote in the context of the donor
history questionnaire FDA recommends
that male or female gender be taken to
be self-identified and self-reported
in a linked document in which they're
talking about what the rules are
supposed to be they're suggesting and
and everyone who's collecting blood I
think it's in the U.S has this is from
the FDA has to abide by these guidelines
uh that blood donors must defer for
three months for the most recent sexual
contact of men who has had sex with
another man during the past three months
and uh
a woman who must defer for three months
from the most recent sexual contact a
female who has had sex during the past
few months with a man who has had sex
with another man in the past three
months so those are the guidelines
supposedly as they stand
and yet back on the red cross's site
under men who have sex with men
they say again the FDA guidance what I
just read
defer for three months from the most
recent sexual contact a man who has had
sex with another man during the past
three months all U.S blood collection
organizations must follow this Federal
requirement but
the Red Cross continues
the Red Cross recognizes the hurt this
policy has caused many in the lgbtq plus
community and believes blood donation
eligibility should not be determined by
methods that are based upon sexual
orientation
we are committed to working with
Partners towards achieving this goal
and when you go into their frequently
asked questions I'm a trans woman and I
have not been eligible to donate because
my assigned sex at Birth was male and I
had sex with a man
can I donate blood
individuals who identify as female and
have sex with a man may be eligible to
donate blood if all other blood donation
eligibility criteria are applicable
if an individual is previously deferred
from donating blood due to men due to
being a man who has sex with men that
person will need to call the donor and
client support center Etc et cetera et
cetera
all you have to do
if you are a man who has sex with men
and has been actively having sex with
men
if you want to donate blood and thus
potentially
corrupt the blood supply
is walk in
and as long as you have not tried this
before
and admitted that you're actually a man
and said nope I'm a wound
and they will let you donate blood
so it's the
it's the ultimate proof that
this
entire societal disorder whatever it is
amounts to the prioritization
of the perceptual world over reality and
not yes so that's the postmodern part
right and then it's a prioritization of
the perceptual world of
mentally ill people
right like
it's one thing to have gender dysphoria
and feel like I really in order to feel
my most true self I need to present as
the sex that I am not it is quite
another thing to say nope
I'm a dude not I never felt like it
either but like it's it's it's a
different it's it's that
is a mental disorder furthermore if you
go in to the Red Cross knowing what
everyone knows about the ways that
things like monkey pox are transmitted
and you say yep I'm a woman yep I've had
sex with men and yes I was assigned to
male at Birth but I'm actually a woman
today and you donate blood knowing that
your psychopath well I I won't say that
I I I don't know people are confused in
a lot of different ways people take
advantage of these confusions in other
ways but I will say
um
the problem is that this actually
in the same era that we have been told
what we absolutely must do for example
take an experimental gene therapy in
order to protect vulnerable people even
if we ourselves do not believe ourselves
to be vulnerable to covid based on well
understood patterns of transmission oh
and by the way it doesn't protect
vulnerable people right it doesn't but
the point is
you know at best they thought it did and
if they did think it did and that's what
was supposed to have morally required us
because protecting other people was the
motivating factor why is protecting
other people not the motivating factor
here and the answer is look
if you
are a biological male
and you have had sex with other men you
can't donate blood right not for a
period of three months right that's
simple nobody's asking you to out
yourself the point is here's the
guideline
don't donate blood if you don't qualify
here's how you'll know and the point is
in order to caused hurt in order to
humor this alternative perspective and
I'm not arguing that there is not a uh a
gentleman's agreement level of decency
if somebody is trend has transitioned
and they wish to be you know called
female fine but the point is that this
does not change things when you get to
the doctor's office it does not change
things when you go to donate blood
there's a physical reality and that's
not about courtesy right that's about
that's about other things in this case
it's about the transmission of a
communicable disease yep
it sure is and uh
here this felt a little bit related uh
don't put it up yet Zack uh
people will probably remember Dylan
Mulvaney the
um the very talented young man who less
than a year ago decided uh that
transitioning publicly on Tick Tock was
actually going to be the way to acquire
the fame that he had clearly so long
desired and um and now has you know days
of girlhood and
um it's quite something
it's quite something and has recently
undergone facial feminization surgery
and has not yet revealed the new
feminized face to the world
um but here is the top of a tick tock
post
for the new year
you may show it in which Dylan Mulvaney
says a friendly reminder as we start the
new year not all trans people desire
affirming surgeries or hormones they are
still trans but when we do it's a
necessity and a win
please show up for all trans people the
way you have showed up for me happy New
Year and love you
you can't have it all the ways
it is an opt-in get out of jail free as
many times as you want it's even better
than monopolies get out of jail free
card because you don't have to turn it
in once you use it all you have to do is
say nope
not the sex I actually am and all the
doors open
including the ability to pollute the
blood supply apparently
why would we open that door for people
why would we do that yeah and
and just the maddening inconsistency
of it I mean really I I'm having a hard
time getting over a society that you
know wants to manipulate us with claims
that we have obligations to keep other
people safe which of course we do have
obligations to keep other people safe
but they often then as soon as you say
well yeah I agree there's a requirement
to keep other people safe then they
smuggle in all the stuff that puts you
in tremendous danger for no obvious
reason well they also redefine safe
right of course and violence and
everything and everything but you know
safe
safe means feeling safe yeah right and
that you know that's
that's been being done for a long time
actually
um are you safe and do you feel safe or
two reasonable questions do you feel
safe and is that the indicator of
whether or not you are safe that is a
there's a logical problem in that and
some people probably are very very good
having been in lots of different kinds
of situations encountered lots of
different kinds of ways that they might
actually not be safe at having those two
things feeling safe and actually being
safe be as tightly coupled as possible
we should all try for that but some
people seem actually interested in
decoupling those things as much as
possible and of crying about not being
safe you know shouting from the rooftops
about how at risk they are and how if
you don't do what they want they're
gonna hurl themselves off the roofs and
when in fact there was no threat
why are we letting them rule
why are we letting them make the
decisions
yeah and frankly it's pretty obvious
that this Society is
not really concerned about safety in any
deep way right the food supply can tell
you that the quality of the air you know
microplastics all of these things are
places where tremendously unsafe stuff
has uh been
produced in such a way that it impacts
the development of children and the
chemicals in the in the water supply
that we're drinking right you know both
from Pharmaceuticals and from
insecticides and pesticides I guess what
I would say
is that every time that same system
which is obviously indifferent to the
harm it does to people right it's gonna
shove Mike Mew out of his profession uh
rather than address the question of uh
you know must we continue to harm
children by feeding them stuff that's
too soft when they're young right it
doesn't care about the well-being of
kids right
um so then every time it uses safety as
his excuse for taking some new kind of
power I officially don't believe it
right right if it was really interested
in safety it would be behaving
differently and even if it wasn't very
good at protecting us it would at least
be consistent in Desiring that we do
things that are safer but hell no I mean
it is
um you know it likes to inflict stuff on
us and it basically laughs when we you
know take the bait
um and then it suddenly shouts safety
and everybody's supposed to adjust
everything about you know either you're
supposed to throw out the precautionary
principle in the interest of safety
right like what the hell is that yes
we're talking safety not precaution
precautions that's dangerous yeah yeah
you're putting everyone in danger with
all that precaution let us do your thing
let us do your thinking for you yeah
yeah nothing's safer than that yeah
indeed
okay well
um
remember the American Natural History
Museum oh I do mnh yes am
American Museum of Natural History I'm
sorry I messed that up it's the American
Museum of Natural History uh and they're
important and big and it's a lovely
Museum in New York but they've also got
um amnet right the the journal one one
of the top journals in in organismal
biology and of course they have what
they may not even own anymore it
certainly went off the rails a long time
ago but the um the lay magazine Natural
History I think that was also mnh
publication for a while
um
well they have apparently it's 150 years
uh you can show my screen here now
um
teen PSI Cafe it's SCI for those who are
not watching so it's teen science cafe
they've got sort of these events uh that
they are running and
it's brought to my attention uh that
an upcoming event is species jumping
viruses this is a week from now
huh so you don't you don't you did not
know what was coming but you're about to
learn okay teen PSI Cafe at the American
Museum of Natural History uh is offering
a little little
little walk through on species jumping
viruses next Saturday what do zika West
Nile Ebola HIV and SARS Kobe 2 all have
in common they are all zoonotic viruses
viruses that affect other species and
have evolved to infect humans who can in
turn pass viruses to other species are
they now
join Mark valatuto vmd senior field
veterination for wait for it the Eco
Health Alliance to learn about how
zoonotic viruses jump from one species
to another and how scientists are using
this information to prepare for and
prevent future pandemics
I I can see the lesson now okay uh
typically a virus will go from its host
species and it will
uh move to an intermediate species like
a ferret Badger or a laboratory of
virology and then it will jump into
humans from there and uh you know well
but usually there's like an intermediate
Vector I would say between ferret Badger
and humans it involves them popsicle
the Frozen ferret Badger Stakes I do
remember that trial balloon well that
was yeah that was a good one that was a
good one I enjoyed that moment yeah so
um ecohealth Alliance for for those who
have have forgotten uh is God I mean
they've had their hand in everything but
um they were the sort of the they were
the pass-through organization right they
were they were the pass-through
organization where NIH
was was giving them the grants and they
were shunting the money to the Wuhan lab
that was doing the gain of function
research that is almost certainly where
SARS Kobe 2 came from meaning like not
subnautic no not unless you're taking a
really big uh definition of zanotic
there and clearly that that's not what
is meant to be implied here but also
then the the president or the founder or
whatever was put on lead on the trip to
China to discover whether or not SARS
Kobe 2 could possibly have come uh from
the lab or much more likely from the
Frozen ferret Badger Stakes uh that um
you know it's basically all of those
very very bad habits of the very very
bad Chinese people but it was us who
were talking about lab leak who were the
racist ones right the ones who thought
that this was uh American work from
North Carolina that had been offshored
to China because of the via the past the
organization that's eco Health Alliance
right yeah also white guys
for example Peter dazek right um the uh
the head of that organization
um yeah it's uh it's
it's unbelievable that they would try to
pawn this off on kids yeah right 14 year
olds and up they do recommend for for
teen Psy Cafe uh that you'd be 14 or
older so um
so have you heard
um Jeffrey sacks talk about this Jeffrey
sax has switched sides in the uh the
origins debate and he's been uh on a
tear because actually he got taken
advantage of as the head of the the
panel looking into the question of
Origins who put Peter dazick on it and
anyway he's fascinating to listen to
yeah
um because basically what he discovered
was that his entire panel had conflicts
of interest and relying right and you
know this is Jeffrey sacks
um so anyway it's
yeah
um
so the American Museum of Natural
History is doing this to us you can put
my screen back up
uh you know what do zika West Nile Ebola
HIV and stars Kobe 2 all have in common
well I hope they don't all have the fact
that they're not synonymic in common I
don't even think about interpretation
um but uh you click through and it's
just easier for me to do this with
screenshots uh past events
teamside Cafe your friendly neighborhood
coyote okay teen Side Cafe Health Equity
racial inequality and covid-19 wait what
okay so let's click through and see what
teamside Cafe this is what the kids call
a risky click Health Equity racial
inequality and covid-19 what do we have
to learn from mnh this was an event that
already happened in November the
covid-19 pandemic disproportionately
affected communities of color across the
U.S but why
how is the legacy of systemic racial
inequality in the United States
contributed to higher rates of infection
and death and lower rates of vaccination
in communities of color
join first Deputy Commissioner and chief
Equity officer of the New York City
Department of Health and mental hygiene
Torreon easterling MD to find out how
the history of medical treatment and
mistreatment in the bipod Community set
the stage for inequities during the
pandemic and what we can do to reach
equity in the future
couple things oh yeah a couple things
people of color
by POC people of color whatever right
have darker skin I was gonna mention
this it's synonymous that's that's a
that's a tautology right
darker skin
is an adaptation
to having had ancestors who are more
recently
um hearkening from close to the equator
and it is a uh is preventative against
skin cancer
in places where there is so much sun
that their need to make vitamin D at the
most optimal rate the most efficient
rate is not there because you're already
getting so much and so what darker skin
does while also being a preventative
against skin cancer is it reduces the
Skin's ability to synthesize vitamin D
which means especially as you being a
dark-skinned person move farther and
farther from the equator and put on more
and more clothes because you're farther
and farther from the equator
you are much more likely to be vitamin D
deficient even than uh you know
white-skinned folk who are living
farther from the equator and also
spending too much time inside and too
much time covered up
white skin is more likely to burn more
likely to result in in Sunburn and
therefore skin cancers but much more
efficient at synthesizing vitamin D we
know
and this has
nothing to do with racism
that dark skin cannot cannot synthesize
vitamin D is effectively and therefore
dark-skinned people who live farther
from the equator are more likely to be
vitamin D deficient and we also know
that vitamin D deficiency is a factor in
bad covet outcomes
both increases the likelihood of
Contracting covet and the Badness of the
interaction with the disease exactly
um it's also true
that the history of racism in the United
States which is true and real have has
has created some you know really
terrible events in African-American
history like
um like Tuskegee right and so African
Americans are appropriately skeptical
when the government comes to them and
says trust us it's safe do it do what we
say
in this case the fact that black
Americans African-Americans are less
vaccinated than their white and Asian
counterparts
apparently was the right move
but
American Museum of Natural History is
looking to redress that inequity
of course they are
um wow uh hiding well we don't know for
sure that they didn't talk about vitamin
D but given the way they set that thing
up basically the idea is the cause of
this is racism right rather than the
cause of this is a physiological
distinction that has
a perfectly well understood explanation
that has nothing to do with anybody
engaging in racism it has to do with the
angle of the sun coming through the
atmosphere and the relative risk of uh
cancer versus vitamin D deficiency and
anyway trade-offs are racist
that's a weird perspective I mean I
guess the the third point you know again
we didn't I didn't even know about this
thing until after it happened and we
obviously weren't there we don't know
what was said so I read the blurb that
was all that was available publicly
but it's also true that it would the
blurb would seem to be implying
that part of the problem was that some
demographics didn't have access to the
vaccines
right everyone had access everybody we
had it was beyond access it was forced
down our throats at every opportunity
all the time you know advertised
everywhere come here go there anywhere
you want it's available it's free it's
easy you must you know it was there was
it was beyond accessible so the idea
that it was racial inequity that kept
black people from getting vaccinated
no no no no no it's uh obviously
Preposterous explanation right you had
to be somewhat clever not to get
vaccinated while you weren't paying
attention yeah
okay
we got the Red Cross losing the plot we
got am and H which I stupidly called
am a and hm first but I got it I did
that and then somehow you dragged me in
and I signed on to them I'm sorry
misspelling of the acronym
again I got taken to sign acronym just
an abbreviation acronyms are
pronounceable
um yeah I'm so right okay so the society
for integrative and comparative biology
wow that feels strangely familiar yeah
oh should we should we done our masks
for this section or not uh I don't know
did you lose yourself I I have my
website yeah so the uh here we go
that is uh that's right said yeah no I
think so yeah so
I can't do it I can't
yeah this is not a very useful way to
prevent
yourself from getting covered but it is
a useful way of signaling something you
pick you picked these up at the
conference at the society for
integrative biology conference is that
right I did I did yeah um well so I mean
but you also picked this up which is
awesome conference program yes they gave
that to me yeah and I have I've begun
reading it and I have some things to
share from it it's actually super
awesome in a lot of ways yes and then
not so awesome in some ways so let me
just say oh wait the pride masks the The
Pride masks have attracted the cat who
has just changed things on my computer
by walking is nothing if not proud
um so let me just say I was in Austin of
course for for The Joe Rogan Experience
and
my hotel turned out to be the epicenter
of this conference which I did not know
was going to be there and it just sort
of emerged around me and I was you know
riding the elevators with these people
um so this was the society for
integrative and comparative biology
which you know that's not a conference I
ever attended it's always it's always at
this moment like it's always during the
winter break for for colleges and one of
one of our friends in grad school used
to always go to it but it's not one I
attended but it is certainly material
much of the the topic the subject area
is stuff that's squarely in the area we
trained in yeah if I don't want to share
a few a few of those so anyway it was
interesting for me I I will say there
was a part of it that was absolutely
surreal because this is a world we used
to be embedded in and now it feels kind
of remote and I was just sort of
watching it anthropologically as you
would certainly have done if you had
been there
and
you know I saw like two kinds of people
and it was really like in some ways
really clear that everybody was in one
category or the other there were
draggled joyless
faculty members right who were clearly
like laboring under the weight of trying
to do this in 2023 and bright-eyed
bushy-tailed graduate students who
have I gotten the memo that they're
going into a field that is dying I mean
part of this is not a field a
Century I don't even know like something
that is they are training for something
that no longer exists
um and it you know a there's a part of
this that's just it's got to just be
what it is to be older right I was
looking at these graduate students and
thinking
we were never that young right that
that's a level of young that just I I'm
sure we were older than that when we
were in graduate school which can't
possibly have been right but anyway
um
and you know there was a lot of like
excitement among these bright-eyed
bushy-tailed graduate students who were
clearly you know ready to you know
confront science it's a big conference
and for some of it would have been their
first big conference lots of
opportunities to meet you know your
future Mentor you know the guy whose
paper you just read and you really want
to ask my questions yeah it's
potentially very exciting it was it was
which also allowed me uh every time I
got on the elevator I was with with
folks from this conference and I was
um very interested to hear their
elevator pitch for what they do which so
you would ask them as you know they
didn't recognize you they know you're a
biologist right and you would say hey
what's it about I said oh are you at the
conference what do you study and I would
get the little elevator pitch for what
they study and sometimes it was
fascinating and sometimes uh they
struggled to
string three consecutive thoughts
together they what it was together and
you know I would ask a good question
they would look at me like what planet
did you come from and
um anyway that sort of thing but it was
it was sort of fun from that that
perspective
um but I will say at some point I became
really curious about what was going on
in there and I decided to kind of Crash
it and I uh I went into the conference
area and
discovered that there was a mask mandate
right which surprised me in yeah I mean
these were not the official masks I will
say there were but they were being
handed out uh yes these were free from
what I've looked into of the conference
that I know what group of people was
handing out the pride masks yeah and I
mean you know
um on the one hand
Pride mask sure on the other hand that
mask isn't useful for this is a biology
conference where they're supposed to be
integrating and that mask is not
evidence of there being on board with
the latest understanding of this
pathogen and how it transmits so this is
basically you know it's a choice to
Signal instead of prevent disease which
you know if that had happened at the
um Modern Art conference right it would
have a little different of an
implication but in this case it was a
little bit strange about the mass
mandate itself yep right and the uh
in any case
my overarching sense was
that you've got this conference
in which well as you're I'm sure going
to point out there were some Oddities in
the material presented at the conference
and there was a context for every event
of the conference which was wearing
masks which are not known to be a
especially useful mechanism to prevent
the transmission of covid and what does
it mean to be at a conference of
biologists in which some fraction of the
material is actually smoke and mirrors
and a biologist should easily see that
right
absolutely so here's just
um
I
I stopped going to conferences before I
should have because I found them
infuriating and meat marketing
um
but I always loved I loved this part of
it and thinking about just as I always
loved a course catalog like thinking
about okay which of these sessions am I
going to go to
and so I went I haven't looked through
all of it yet it's it's long and online
you can find the abstract if this had
the abstracts it would be you know 10
times as thick more than that
um but just from the titles I see a lot
to be excited about at this conference
which is still going on right now
they're having like their end of it's a
long conference second through the
seventh third through the seventh so it
started when you halfway through you you
being in Austin
um
you know they've got sessions on
evolution of behavior sexual selection
communication Locomotion uh an entire
session called I think yeah entire
session called heads or tails control
surfaces and Aquatic locomotion
boom
uh just from just three pages I've got
um
these three talks rules for emergent
synchrony during bioluminescent behavior
of sea fireflies
so you know how is it rules for emergent
synchrony during bioluminescent behavior
of C fireflies I never heard of a sea
Firefly before yeah but how do these
presumably Marine insects
um
end up syncing up what they're doing now
wait a minute fireflies see fireflies
yeah I know yeah but fireflies proper
all I've got is the title incidentally
so we can talk about this but I've got I
got nothing we're gonna speculate and if
SC fireflies are offended that's gonna
be they can write a sternly worded
letter okay
um but in actual fireflies all I've got
is the authors that doesn't help no yeah
in actual fireflies
you've got two kinds of synchrony
you could potentially have synchrony of
emergence which is kind of implied by
that title yes and you could have
synchrony of luminescing right so there
are some fireflies on Earth in which a
tree will luminesce in sync
we don't know which that is we don't
know which it is no and I mean that in a
way that actually makes for a really
cool talk because you're like oh I want
to know
or if you were actually deciding between
you know this and one of the like 10
other concurrent sessions you would
probably go online look at the abstract
and see if if they were actually doing
anything interesting before going and
spending whatever it was I didn't even
look 10 or 12 minutes at the talk
um
another title that I thought I would
have been interested to go to if I had
if I had been at this conference
alligators use elastic energy storage
and Ankle extensions during steady state
walking
ankle extension tackle extension walking
so this put me in mind of uh
Arcus or ankles which you can just very
quickly Zach put this on screen and then
take it down because I'm not going to
walk through it but this is a slide for
my Orchestra Evolution lecture back when
I gave Arkansas Revolution lectures
arcosaurus being
birds dinosaurs and crocodilians and
argosaur ankles
um
are variable and like think about a bird
and think about how they walk along uh
on on their legs and they don't uh they
just kind of like pad along I can't
really do it because I got cats in a
computer and everything whereas if
you've ever watched video of or been
lucky enough to be around a crocodilian
crocodile alligator gariel Cayman
um usually they kind of sit in this in
this position right and they and they
even will move a little bit in the slow
position but if you excite them or anger
them or scare them they will move their
their legs under them and they do a high
walk that can be very very fast
and that is because they've got this
thing called a chronotarsal ankle in
which they can basically have their have
their bones in this orientation or in
this orientation it's stable both ways
uh whereas uh the other archosaurs the
birds and the dinosaurs uh were stuck in
the sort of like five footed position so
if
they were to be attacked by
hymenopterans of some kind they could
Scurry away rapidly
and if I studied that and I was going to
deliver a talk it could be archosaurus
ants and ankles
okay all right
I'm not sure it's worth it it wasn't
worth it Anthony
as opposed to aunts and uncles never
mind I just thought I'd try it
you know yes that when you do that sort
of thing it makes the the person who
you're doing it to think
and listening to what I was saying no I
was no no no no no on on the contrary
um I was listening you had to be
listening to some of it yes yeah and I I
noted your beautiful diagram and was
impressed that you know you happen to
have a slide on this exact topic well so
elastic energy storage and Ankle
extensions I assume that that talk on
alligators at this conference yeah still
going on right now uh was actually about
soft soft tissue
um elastic energy storage all right that
sounds like soft tissue rather than
rather than bone but it's it's related
well elastic energy storage is going to
be like the the bounce that comes from
not uh Contracting a muscle but yeah
that's soft that's that's the soft issue
so it's going to be ligaments tendons
muscles on the ligaments and tendons
um and then just one more one more title
um war and sex in the tropics
performance trade-offs in the world's
largest Semel Paris mammals
so I'm I'm sharing this and I'll read
that again for you to for you to parse
it I'm sharing these in part because
kind of these academic conferences may
seem from the outside like they couldn't
have any value at all they'd be really
boring everything but you know people
are having fun with the titles they're
having fun with the abstracts having fun
with the science like if the science
isn't enjoyable to do do some other kind
of science or don't do science at all
right so war and sex in the tropics
performance trade-offs in the world's
largest seminal Paris mammals
um I don't know that I actually did in
this case go to the abstract because I
was like what do these think the world's
largest SEMO Paris mammals are Semel
Paris just refers to an organism that
has sex has one mating event maybe it
may be a short period of events but then
dies so for instance Pacific salmon
famously do you know spend all this
non-repredictive time out at Sea and
then they return that's the anatomy part
um back to their natal stream and they
have a series of mating events and then
they die they do not go back out to sea
and come back back and have another so
this is gonna have to be a rodent it's
uh no it's a marsupial
it's the qual
q-u-o-l-l the qual but
um even they're abstract so what where
we're talking about now is what is uh
the world's largest seminal Paris mammal
that is a mammal
um that by by its very being has sex
wants or has a brief mating season and
then dies and doesn't have another
Mating Season afterwards
um but I take slight issue because as it
turns out Qualls are the males are
almost always similar Paris but the
females actually have a couple of things
now that you mentioned so it's one sex
symbol parody and the other sex not so
much but anyway it made for a good title
yep yeah uh so it's probably both the
world's largest and smallest arguably
some of Paris mammal
well I yes unless there's another right
there within that clay to marsupials I
think because there aren't any placental
ammas which is like all the mammals you
can think of that aren't
um
um
uh
what's the fun in the New World
the more Superior
daidelphis um yeah possums possums yeah
um basically if it's not a possum or it
lives in Australia it's probably a
placenta unless it's a kidnap or a
platypus okay we're now driving people
driving people away okay
um
yeah I'll skip that let me skip that
um
integrative biology incubator how do
plants animals fungi and algae solve the
same problems differently
it's a brainstorming Workshop that they
had and what they say in the description
of the brainstorming Workshop what blind
spots become apparent in our core
biological Concepts when we compare and
contrast solutions from different
biological kingdoms
yes that's the sort of thing that should
be happening at scientific conferences
pull people together from all over the
world mostly the us but all over the
world and put those who want to be there
in a room together and say okay you have
expertise in frogs and you have
expertise in tomatoes and you have
expertise in morels and you know how do
they all solve the problem of getting
of of growing of getting nutrients of
you know whatever it is of cell recovery
you know whatever it is when are these
Solutions shared and between which
clades and when are they different and
how what can we learn like that's
awesome that's part of what drove me to
be interested in biology if well done
awesome if well done awesome
however
however
there were nine symposia at the conflict
symposia basically being conferences
within a conference so a symposia has
sort of a higher level of prestige than
just the um just the sessions it's been
organized carefully
and you probably had to sort of submit
something it was a higher standard to be
admitted in both to be a symposium and
then to be able to talk at the symposium
and um several of those several symposia
look really fascinating one of them was
biology at Birth the role of infancy and
providing the foundation for Lifetime
success
and a number of really interesting talks
but there's also the sexual diversity
and variation symposium
which I suspect it was those people who
were handing out These Guys these Pride
masks
it doesn't did include some talks that
appear to be actual science
um but it's mostly a smorgasbord of
self-indulgent confusion and was
co-organized by a graduate student
who will no doubt go far given that he's
playing by all the current ideological
roles and Fashions but his Twitter
profile and I'm not going to share
details or specifics of exactly who he
is or what his institution is so I'm
I've taken out the identifying features
here
um Twitter profile reads without the
identifying features
queer trans evolutionary biologist
aspiring plant hashtag cycom cycom drag
King relentlessly Earnest they them
this is one of the co-organizers of one
of the symposia at one of the biggest
biology conferences going on
at all and it happens to be going on
right now some of the talk titles
organized by this they them queer trans
evolutionary biologist aspiring plant
person
um are
linnaean Libertines
the queer possibilities of plants
and and this one appears to be from the
lab of someone who should know better
but the talk is fluidity and inconstancy
Australian bush tomatoes solanum as an
Exemplar of non-normative sex expression
in plants and across life
non-normative sex expression implants
normative normative in tomatoes
well if you were going to have something
non-normative I mean Australian bush
tomatoes right right sure pretty
non-normative
as far as plants go in the direction of
non-normativity I would imagine that
tomatoes and especially the Australian
bush variety would be at the top of the
list it was the low-hanging fruit
[Music]
pretty well done actually yeah
um
but all right so this this does
seriously people I mean come on this
does get to the the central question
though is my my claim is if you have I
don't know how many people were at this
conference that's a big conference it's
a big conference if you have all of
these people actively involved in
academic biology
studiously not making eye contact with
the fact that there are supposed a
symposia that make no sense going on at
the conference where they are abiding by
mandates that make little sense at the
conference where they are the field
doesn't exist because the basic the idea
is
the whole point of science is you're
supposed to follow the evidence using
the high the the hypothetical deductive
method of science to figure out what is
actually true and that is the North Star
to the extent that a field is going to
kowtow to fiction right then it's not a
scientific field and it doesn't matter
that it may occasionally do something
scientific because the point is it has
signed up for a value system in which
something else apparently has priority
and you know I mean I I don't know
anything about this person who organized
the Symposium but
you can certainly imagine knowing what
we saw in Academia as you say a person
is likely to go far why because nobody's
going to be in a position to say
actually that work wasn't good enough
that work didn't mean anything what's
more it wasn't scientific right because
if you did say that to somebody who
claimed to be
trans then the point is oh well you're
discriminating against me because I'm
trans check and MIT check and mate and
also I mean he he's doing it very
effectively now because just like
publisher Parish used to be the rule of
law in Academia and it sort of expanded
to well also you're expected to do
Outreach and you're supposed to have all
of these different kinds of experiences
where and you engage with with the
broader community and so it's not just
publishing peer-reviewed academic papers
you know on which we've talked a lot
about the problems there
um but that you know that had been sort
of the gold standard
this person has now organized a
symposium at one of the largest
biological conferences and previously
gave a talk and another given invited
talk at another conference and those two
things on a CV applying from applying
out of grad school for a postdoc
that's huge most people don't have that
most most grad students don't have that
so you know and yet the topics of both
the talk which they're not going to
spend time on here and this Symposium at
this conference are not scientific
there's there's no science there as far
as I can tell
um and you know no I wasn't there and
they don't have the talks up yet they
are going to post the talks and I was
going to watch them but they're not up
yet
but it it gives the appearance it's like
it's it's it's it's potemkin science
it's potemkin Academia it's you know
this this facade and all you have to you
know the line on the CV is what
potential employers you know academic
employers will be looking for like oh
well look at you aren't you a go-getter
haven't you done a lot of good work like
well I did do work
doesn't look great was good no but it's
even it's even worse than that I'm sure
um well here's how it's worse
imagine that your core uh desire in life
was
trans activism yeah you know you know
it's a real pain in the ass if you're a
trans activist
evolutionary biology right so if you if
your core thing was to shut those
evolutionary biologists up right people
who understand that reef fish aren't the
invalidation of binary sex right
um You might go get yourself one of them
fancy phds in evolutionary biology and
you might wield it like a weapon so I'm
expecting that we're going to see this
emerge as you know and you know and you
can imagine unless the world gets over
the idea
that as soon as you're trans you're
right you know as soon as we get over
that idea we can skip this but until
then what this means is that as this
person is able to set up symposia and
give invited talks in order that people
can you know I don't know satisfy their
cow Towing obligations or whatever right
this person is going to gain power and
that power is going to be used for what
I call Ideal laundering right he's he's
going to launder wrong ideas into
evolutionary biology which is going to
make it harder and harder to do high
quality evolutionary biology because you
know are you going to cite it are you
going to ignore it what do you do right
um and I will point out I I think it's
Michelle Foucault
who essentially argued to Trojan Horse
fields to enter them and disrupt their
ability to do what they do maybe it was
Marcus but I think it was Foucault but
in any case it's somebody's idea that
the purpose of this stuff is actually
its activism and disruption and so you
know
wake up evolutionary biologists there's
one headed your way yeah right and you
know it's already inside the house right
the call is now coming from inside the
house and I will just say you know
this is not to say that trans people
shouldn't be able to do evolutionary
biology but if your purpose is to just
disrupt evolutionary biology with
nonsense stuff right I mean the fact is
if you land in evolutionary biology as a
trans person
what are the chances that you also land
on that as your topic
right in other words why are you not
studying chelation in the scales of a
you know fence lizards or something
right why are you studying that exact
thing and does that not suggest that
maybe you've landed there because
evolutionary biology is not your top
priority but something else is exactly
so I will I've told this story before
but
um the the line in the in the bio of the
person who co-organized the Symposium
queer slash trans evolutionary biologist
whenever I see something modifying
evolutionary biologist that isn't
that isn't like a
a narrowing of what kind of evolutionary
biologist you are yeah
um I think to uh I know exactly what
you're saying yeah yeah you know the
story I'm gonna tell
um
I think to when I was trying to uh sell
my first book antipode
and it was about my research and life in
Madagascar and I had uh I had a good
agent and he was pitching it and this
was long before we ever lived
um in Portland or anywhere in the
Pacific Northwest but actually there was
a small press in Portland that showed
that showed the first interest and I
ended up getting it published by a major
publishing house but the small press
showed interest
and they were offering you know nice
amount of money for a grad student maybe
he already made any money at all at that
point
um and they were super interested
because they said
um it's a story of feminist science
I said nope
can't can't go there won't go there
because that's not a thing
and they're like what do you mean it
feels you know okay so and there's
actually there's no mention of feminism
in the book but I said well you know as
a woman who goes alone in these places
you must be a feminist and at that point
this would have been
late 90s early odds it's like you know I
actually do I did still think of myself
as a feminist at that point but um
that's separate from being a scientist
and you can't modify scientists with uh
feminist because the feminism is an
ideological position
and uh and if that is informing if that
is modifying linguistically scientist
then your science is suspect and your
science is flawed and you aren't holding
the scientific process as the thing that
is most important because if you're
doing science and you ask a question
that comes up with an answer that you
you come up with an answer that you
don't like you're not expecting you wish
weren't true
it's still the answer
and if you are informing your science
with some ideology which is likely to
have you push some answers and deep six
others then you're not really doing
science so same thing queer trans
evolutionary biologist like you can be
it was talking like no one can Define
queer so just put queer no no no no
two things one it's not the story I
thought you're gonna tell but
the fact that queer shows up
without a meaning in this case right
right is in and of itself an indication
that something is up here right how is
it not redundant with trans
yeah but I mean like you could as you
already said like you can be trans and
you can be an evolutionary biologist but
putting them together oh validates the
scientist part totally agree but the
fact of putting queer and trans together
as a co-modifier right that sounds like
it's rather full of meaning what exactly
is that meaning yeah right so I once
yeah long ago tweeted uh something like
if the queue were removed from lgbtq who
exactly would be excluded and got not a
single useful answer okay
um so saying well then what is this
community right I'm not saying there's
no Community but I'm saying why is there
an extra letter in there if not as some
kind of
um mechanism to do something other than
convey meaning yeah if there's no
meaning but the story I thought you were
going to tell
was when we were at Evergreen there was
a hire that was Advanced for a feminist
Economist and you and I both raised this
exact issue saying
no yeah an economist is supposed to
describe how economics works and the
idea that you've put an ideological
modifier on it means that's not what
you're doing right you've effectively
advertised a filter so it's the same
same meaning as no when I when I argued
against that position because I think
both you and I were on sort of the
general hiring committee to decide at
that point so we both got supposedly had
some voice there but didn't make a
difference I believe I told the story
that I just told here then too because
it
it just it can't work that way and
everyone is buying the Press of for the
people who are claiming to be the most
the most damaged and and hurt by
societal strictures and we just we just
have to stop yeah we have to we have to
stop
yep
I'm an environmental mathematician
I don't know okay
um okay one last thing
uh we just lost half of our life yep all
right no we got mood lighting for the
one last thing let's just
no let's play it as a feature it's play
it as a feature well I'm gonna I'm gonna
keep going yeah
okay
um
so I went looking this week uh for
reasons that may become clear in Natural
Selections in my sub stack
um for some of my old music books
and in looking for some of my old music
books
I found
I found this
our Natural Science World
a project of the tri actually Zach I
need you back here to show my screen
Fairfax can you do it hey Zach
like I actually can't do this without
the screen
um
not sure what to do
Zach here talk about it he'll come back
the lighting is much less important than
actually being able to show the screen
here
um
it's like I need to show my screen
okay so I found
um
I found this and it turns out to be a
a work a piece of work that I did in
fourth grade
uh when I was
uh this was right
this is right around when uh kids in LA
in the public schools were being bussed
and so I was being bussed for half a
year and I was at Baldwin Hills and this
is at the end of the year science lab
and I do this uh this bit on uh it's a
16-page document in fact
um that sounds like you
here's the table of contents wow color
coded in everything God's like that
scientific instruments three natural
science kingdoms what uh which
apparently are mineralogy plants and
animals
oh it's like 20 questions oh man
um and I mean there's some really good
stuff in here I I gotta say
um and I only I'm only gonna show you
five pages I've only I've already showed
you tune show you two
um so you know we got
mineralogy what makes soil plant
propagation invertebrates
uh vertebrates fish class amphibian
class reptilia class AVS class and
classmomelia so
um you know very typical uh for for the
era and for elementary school even in a
you know advanced
fourth grade science class uh we have
for instance qriket observation I mean
look at this yeah pretty well done here
you've got you know I did the little the
the drawing of the various parts of the
cricket and I even give it to like the
temperature formula at the bottom for
um how to tell what temperature it is by
how many chirps they've got going per
minute you know I got I got some good
stuff here
um
but then we get to vertebrates
um
um I don't even know what the amiibo
looking thing is supposed to be my best
guess is the cross-section of a vertebra
but it doesn't really work but whatever
I'm not not really totally sure what's
going on there and I've got the five
groups of vertebrates again you know
this is not actually how Evolution
worked but I got a really unhappy
looking frog but it's the only one I did
in color and AVS is represented by it
looks like a cat got to it yeah it's
just two feathers uh reptilia
represented by the snake as you know I
was already into snakes so I'm doing
snakes and then the mammal mammaly as I
as I describe it there is I think that's
just fur
like the birds and the mammals both got
just like their representative things
glass of milk
yeah
um but you know you know large size long
lives mostly not many started 420
million years ago I got like some some
good stuff in here
but um I was just flipping through this
I was all alone you were in Austin I'm
like I don't remember anything about
this I don't remember anything about
even making this this book at all it was
clearly it was a big big project uh and
then I get to the birds
Aries backbones feathers endothermic
beaks or bills good brain eyesight Keen
hearing
um Audubon I don't know what that means
Audubon okay like he studied Birds sure
yes and then finally and there's a lot
more good stuff here but I have I have
the classifications of the birds okay
you ready yeah okay so we got four types
of birds
four types of birds water Birds
predatory Birds unusual birds and pet
birds
okay yeah
all right
and I I have to say that despite despite
such Ridiculousness I got an
of course you did over course you know
even as unusual birds and pet birds
of course there are some unusual birds
and there are some pet birds there are
there are there are no I feel uh
strangely teleported back to
um was it fourth grade fourth grade yeah
my fourth grade self and I feel uh
unable to compete with that
overachieving girl who doesn't know when
to quit with her for
type some birds and yeah oh my God no
yeah no it was it's I mean there's more
I'm not I'm gonna stop yeah I at the
point that I got to pet birds is one of
the categories of birds yeah don't show
that to Arnold
my graduate advisor uh he would not
approve
um so anyway that's it I was trying I
was I was trying to not lose the plot
yeah back and forth grade trying to
figure out the plot I mean I mentioned
Kendrick these in there hey look at that
and so we were lit and thus there is
life and thus there was again light who
knows how long
um
that's all I got all right well I think
we've arrived there okay
um there are no doubt questions uh there
will be I think there will be questions
and we will endeavor to answer them
indeed and so you can ask questions at
darkhorsesubmissions.com uh there will
certainly be already some questions
there but you can continue to ask
questions
and
um again we encourage you to join our
patreons where you can have access to
our thriving Discord Community uh and
Brad is having a conversation on his
patreon tomorrow evolutionary
evolutionary conversation at 9 00 a.m
Pacific
uh come find me at Natural Selections
and sub stack read our book and until we
see you next time be good to the ones
you love eat good food and get outside
and if you see the plot please let us
know where it's gone so we can alert
some folks
[Music]